and I do not believe for one second that
one female has started dating him not
knowing that he's like that they know
what they're getting themselves into so
they can't then complain that he's not
letting here not letting them go out or
whatever because it's their choice to be
with him they know that he's like that
not all men are like that every men have
their own opinions and and differ in how
they treat like their partner but you
can't tell me that they don't know that
he's gonna be like that what do you guys
think yeah no 100 I think
if you're going to date someone like
that you kind of already know their
views and their standpoints so for me
you're kind of signing up to that
because you've made it very clear from
the offset
um but do I agree with him no I
personally don't I don't think um clubs
are all about sex some people generally
generally do just want to go out and
have a good time with their friends or
whoever they're going out with and I
think personally when it comes to
relationships you should be allowed to
go out and still live your just because
you're in a relationship it's not a
prison sentence you should still be able
to go out and live your life and do what
you want to do I think it comes down to
trust like okay even if I did end up on
a guy's table you should trust in me
that nothing's going to happen in that
sense if anyone does try to approach me
I've got a boyfriend I've got a man
that's it but the girls that I might be
with they're single they're having a
good time whatever I'm just there
because you know I'm with my friends and
that's what it is I think it all boils
down to trust at the end of the day but
I think a VIP table yeah no Madam no no
it's two personally I don't think so
how's that I don't think that's personal
because look at the connotations there's
like a bunch of fellas got VIP we're the
Kings and you've got your woman go into
that section where it's cornered off for
what purpose attention you know with
like this whole you go into a club and
the guy picking up girls from clubs you
know you can go to the corner shop right
and a guy that has I don't know status
or money you're good looking can still
actually take your girl I mean if your
girl's loyal and you trust each other
it's not gonna happen I always feel like
it doesn't matter what environment
you're in if you're a loyal person it's
not going to happen I think also people
don't go to the corner shop to get
picked up
the majority of the majority of people
go to the club to end up with someone
but you can be walking down the street
and a guy is driving past and beep soon
that could be some I don't know some
rich celebrity I don't know who he is
and that's a second it can happen
anywhere that's acceptable because
that's out of her reach but a VIP can I
ask why would okay let's say you're
taken the reason the majority of the
reason why you'll be in that video IPS
because your girls are single so
therefore when you look at as a whole
you're there because the majority of the
reasons people are single that you're
with yeah so then what happens with you
what kind of message will that be
sending out in any form even if you even
if you're loyal and you're doing what
you're doing yeah but why why are you
there yeah so what I must say sit at
home and wear my pajamas in a VIP that's
why I can't be in VIP just because I'm
in a relationship I mean yeah it's
disrespectful I think so if one of her
friends
like I said it's each of their own I
personally don't think that's
disrespectful in any guy I don't because
for me personally I think just because
you're in the VIP you could still be in
the normal part of the club and still
get picked up by a guy or talk to
whoever is it like this goes back to
your into it's your intent is at the end
of the day just flipping what Tammy T
said to be fair so let's flip the script
let's say it's you and your boys on a
night out you've got a VIP table let's
say you're in a relationship and let's
say all your friends are single yeah
same thing happens your friend goes out
picks up a load of girls comes on the
table and stuff and you're there you're
not leaving are you I'm checking I I I'm
precautions I'll even make it worse
we're in a strippers I've already
violated I'm violating as it is I'll
check in with my baby look babes this is
what's going on I don't need any girl
snapping her saying look at him because
that's what happens I just came back
from Marbella I saw that live in the
flesh some girl was filming another guy
and I don't know what happened after but
how do you know some girls if let's say
they weren't a VIP table let's just say
that was the case they're not talking to
their partner and saying by the way babe
I'm on a table tonight X Y and Z let's
just say you have that communication
with your partner and you've let them
know that that's fine with that because
either because me personally I'm engaged
yeah yeah and a lot of my friends are
single so I've been out and let's say
there is a situation at where that's
happened I speak to my fiance quite
frequently when I'm out so if there is
if there ever is a situation especially
with social media I'm gonna let him know
straight away but like this is a
situation
but then I wouldn't say I'm gonna leave
my friends and be like bye I'm engaged
so I can't stand there no it's the fact
that
no one can go back and say this is
what's happened because I've already
told him yeah but the way I conduct
myself when I'm there every guy that
there knows don't even bother talk to me
every guy that's there is gonna know do
you know what don't even bother with her
again it's all about the way you kind of
come off yeah like if you're in a
relationship with somebody and you're
coming off and you're it's all about
your body language everyone can read
your body language I think you give off
a Vibe if you're
um I'm kind of open but I'm not a man
knows that if a woman's very standoffish
like this don't talk to me he's not
approaching you because he knows you
know what there's just no point in her
leave her alone well what you said is
very acceptable by the way because I
said I'll do the same thing I'm not
gonna leave of course but yeah if I let
it if I'm clear about things or I show
her but the fact is that's not really
happening that common I think that we
know we know this we know this people
will do things be like Oh I'm
independent maybe from a woman's side
they're too independent why should I
have to do that and the man's side it
goes without saying that's been
happening from day one um
I think the point is you're just putting
yourself in a situation where like it
could be a bad situation where guys are
coming at you and it's just like I when
I'm like I'm single now but when I was
in a relationship I didn't even go to
clubs because I just feel like why would
I want to put myself in that situation
like I can hang out with my friends we
can get lunch we can have girls I think
that shows how different like different
people view how they should be in their
relationship like Andrew Tate for
example is you know Territorial and
that's how he acts in a relationship
some people would feel comfortable going
to a club with their girlfriends and you
know not paying any attention to guys
whatever but personally I've been a
long-term relationship I wouldn't feel
comfortable going to a club with a load
of my single friends because I know the
majority of the reason they're going to
the club is to try and find men and then
what happens if all of them go home with
the man I'm left on my own out in town
vulnerable on my own whatever and like I
wouldn't find that fun I wouldn't say
because I'm in a long-term relationship
I wouldn't go to a club but I wouldn't
go without my partner because I don't
think I'd enjoy it otherwise just second
in onto it you said actually about the
whole going out with your friends I
think it's your friend's intention I
think you need to know your friend and
I'm not saying you don't know I'm not a
cabin at you at all like that but I
would say I think you need to know your
friends I think to be honest with you if
I I wouldn't go out with a group of
girls and there are 10 I mean none of my
friends are like that none of my friends
I mean I'm speaking generally yeah 90 of
my friends are in long-term
relationships and they're also like yeah
and that's fine and I'm not and I wasn't
speaking about you directly I'm just
talking about generally speaking
sometimes because we see it you go out
and sometimes girls you see other girls
leave their friends I don't understand
that mindset because for me me and my
circle we're one if we go left we all go
left no one's getting left home no one's
going home with no guys that's not how
we operate so for me I can go out with
single girls to wherever because we're
going out to have a good time yes if my
single friend gets approached by a guy
she might get approached by a guy they
may swap numbers but the end of the
night she's not leaving me like she's
not looking at me as your specific
friend yeah law engagement with your
partner whatever and and the trust and
the like the it
conversations that you guys have had and
how you know each other but not everyone
is like 100 but that's why I said I
think it depends when we're saying
obviously about